il y a un an une équipe
d'astrophysiciens publier la toute
première photographie d'un trou noir un
événement exceptionnel jusque là il ne
disposait que de simulation alors que là
il s'agit d'une véritable photographie
du trou noir m87 ses deux longues
l'objet se trouve à 55 millions d'années
lumière de la terre c'est loin mais il
vaut mieux regarder cette forme si je
lâche elle tombe cet accroc de la
gravitation universelle dans l'univers
tous les corses affirmé plus la masse
est importante plus la gravitation est
importante c'est pourquoi la pomme va
vers la terre et non l inverse
ce trou noir est si massif 6,5 milliards
de fois la masse du soleil qui la tire
vers lui tous ceux qui se trouvent dans
les parages y compris sa propre lumière
qui ne parvient pas à s'échapper et qui
restent confinés voilà pourquoi on parle
de trou noir
même cette capsule de des conflits n'est
ni résisterez pas aller à demain et
n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain